okay [ __ ] i have some questions for you
you ready i'm ready okay what celebrity
have i had the chance to interview that
gave you major fomo
don't act like you don't know who i've
interviewed dolly parton a lot of
giggles a lot of giggles what is one
thing you wish you could have told your
younger self i think i would have said
don't worry about eating the donuts
it's okay if you are a little chubbier
than the rest of the kids don't let that
hurt your feelings
one day you could even be on television
life is too short not to eat the donut
right
absolutely
or the cheesecake
um
well you did eat the cheesecake and i
probably did eat the donut too right
the bush sisters have teamed up for
their second children's book the
superpower sisterhood about a little
girl with no siblings who forms a
special bond with her best friends it's
inspired by their mom laura who grew up
an only child she has the same best
friends
that she had since she was
little in midland still and those are
her sisters those are her chosen sisters
mom obviously instilled in us the love
of reading and books how do you hope to
pass that same love on to your own kids
well i hope i'm doing it
through this through not only writing
books but also just modeling reading i
mean mom and dad read constantly to us
and then read before to themselves
before they went to bed and so they
still do they still do every single
night so we witnessed what it looks like
to fall in love with books what was one
time we were more powerful together than
we were when we were apart
well we only know the world together i
mean there was that one minute i had
without you how was that minute
it was very relaxing it was relaxing
without me
and then you sprung into the world but
we leaned on each other in so many ways
i mean do you remember when we went to
the inauguration for dad and we were
stiletto heels and we'd never worn
stiletto heels in our life we were like
holding on to each other
and by the way the marble steps of the
capital are not forgiving they don't
absorb no they don't absorb there's no
shock absorbers there's no it's just
straight into marble who amongst your
today's show family do you count as some
of your super power sisters of course
hoda um i
rely on her in so many ways not just at
work hoda got the big exclusive with
prince harry no it does remind me of the
time when i interviewed him and i tried
to set you up with him you did she's
available she's going to kill me we can
talk maybe off here okay i'll give you
her number you could have been a
princess you idiot
i want to hear about what life is like i
think she's going to talk with him about
megan i want to hear what that meeting
with the queen was like i'm dying to
know well hoda did go there with harry
as we see in a preview of tomorrow's
interview that will air on today when
hoda sat down with him at the invictus
games how did it feel
being with her it was great it was it
was just so nice to see her making i had
tea with her so it was really nice to
catch up with her and you know home
home for me now is is you know for the
time beings
[Music]